of course they gotta talk to you about
Rhonda are you guys still together so
Rhonda and I yes we are still working on
making things all work oh there has been
there have been ups and downs challenges
as there were at the retreat but we are
definitely still yeah we're still
rocking wow so she's your girlfriend yes
so so initially once we came home from
her retreat run Rhonda and I kept
contact we're going we're doing well for
a few months on and then kind of whoof
work on because I was coaching I work at
a school with children special needs
um and I'm a personal trainer so working
all that it's tough I kind of got busy
um my mom fell ill so I kinda that kind
of caused me to like work on and
everything I was going on here
um and then weak so we took a break for
a few weeks and then we got back and it
was like nothing like we picked up
basically where we left off so things
are going well prior to the coronavirus
happening we have made plans of visiting
each other so um and there's been talk
to like who's gonna move or are we
looking at relocate so kind of acting
means make things work wow so and did
you meet her son yes so I did get to
meet her son um well I met her I met her
once while we were at the retreat
um and then I got to FaceTime with him a
lot he's gonna meet amazing great kid um
so we've definitely started to go to
bond Wow
so what kind of things are you guys
talking about for your future where do
you see the relationship going so we
actually were we were talking about
relocating to LA hopefully move in LA
and kind of just continuing our careers
I got it my past like we're basically
both interested in the same stuff um I
like to hopefully get into motivational
speaking and she wants to do the same
thing or like she has a like a line that
she's trying to work on right also and
it's perfect like I mean she already has
a kid that I can look at being what am I
like looking at it is my own so it's a
great opportunity so are you in love
um I have love for her yes I have a lot
I don't look for um Rhonda is somebody
that I felt like she came through at a
at a very special time in my life where
I was going through so much and for her
to stick it out and be there for me
through all
it never turned back or never used to me
saying like she understood me when I
think when I thought that no one else
could so I have a lot of love for I
won't quite say I love her yet but I can
definitely see it getting here one day
if we continue to to grow together
so what's it been like to be able to
hook up in the real world after filming
ended so I I've been I've been stand
true to myself and it's answered to
Rhonda so I haven't done anything since
we've gone home
yeah I've been serious yeah so I gave
her my word while we were on the show
like this is like this is it like I want
to try if I'm gonna try it with anyone I
wanted to be with her so I've been I've
been saying it staying true today um and
I've been holding out I can't say I
haven't been so gratifying but
everything else I mean there's no money
being deducted well yeah everything else
I've been just intro so but you and
Rhonda have seen each other right so
what's it been like for you guys to get
to hook up with each other out in the
real world fine life so we haven't
hooked up either oh we did we did yeah
we haven't hooked up either
um the the only time that we really got
to spend with each other was at the
retreat and then um prior to leaving so
we haven't yeah other than that we
haven't physically seen each other since
the show that's been a year right yeah
it's been a year so we've been faced
time and we fall asleep on the phone all
the cute lovey-dovey stuff but we
haven't seen each other that's why it
was so crazy that we were about to meet
and then all of a sudden in front of
others heaven is like oh wow and you
hooked up with anybody else no one in a
year so how much did the show change you
I think it changed me tremendously my
last relationship which was in 2016 Oh
4:15 oh my ex cheated on me with my best
friend so it was like I trusted and I
put my faith in my trust in one person
and then you let me down and with
someone like my best friend that really
hurt me so I kind of built up a wall and
it was just like I wasn't sleeping
around that well I was meeting women and
sleeping around because I hope I had
hoped that that would have got me over
my ex like I was so heartbroken and so
distraught um and I was I was devastated
so I started this path where I was
sleeping around what
Joe and I started to at one point I
started pushing around away but I
realized that like at some point I
started to have feelings I'm like I
literally cry not so her I said look I'm
not here for the money at one point I
was I'm not I'm not here to win the
money I'm here to just have fun but I
told her I was like I'm starting care
for you that if I sleep with you I'm
gonna revert back to my old ways I'm
gonna go back to the ocean well I came
in here and I don't want to beat it I
want to be a better person and I think
you just observe more so if I sleep with
you is like I'm doing you a disservice
[Music]